[Applaudissements]
possible parce que par la présente à vous le mot
à retirer si vous n'utilisez pas le masque
laissez tomber
Ils ont
Je ne me laisse pas du tout être ici
te parler et c'est ici
organisé par arrêté général
la dépêche du parlement de l'état de porter un
bouche nez protection mais aucun aucun
masque de carnaval ou autre
peut être en tout cas tu sais
toi-même que tu es ici
plus compris ou soja
se moquer de
elle met le masque maintenant
pourtant le mot
[Applaudissements]
la
[La musique]
ont déposé en commission du cinquième
où lui échapper à nouveau dans le mot
si vous n'enlevez pas votre masque maintenant